and he he takes so many questions and
has been
we're waiting for of course joe biden to
take more but maybe we're seeing why he
can't
now wisconsin may not be the only swing
state joe biden has to worry about
minnesota may not be as blue as the
biden campaign thinks
especially now that six mayors from
democrat cities in blue collar
iron mining districts have declared
they'll be voting for president trump
in november in an open letter they wrote
we didn't choose to leave the democratic
party the party left us now that's of
course we also know that as a statement
from president reagan many of us
can relate to that one of those mayors
andrea zaponsich
mayor of babbitt minnesota joins me now
mayor thank you so much for joining us
it's a
it's a heated time for those of us who
enjoy politics
i want to ask you have other mayors or
other local officials
express similar views to you about or
are they worried um uh to say the least
about
perhaps what the economic ruin uh biden
would bring uh
tell us what are your thoughts on that
and what other people may be saying to
you at this point
oh yeah definitely all of those points
those are their biggest concerns about
what's going to happen in the economy
um if it goes the other way and i can
tell you one more mayor has stepped up
now so there are seven of us in the
group
um mayor vreeland from white lakes so
it's great yeah it is and i think people
are more step are stepping up more now
and they're realizing you know what we
are a silent majority and we're done
um keeping our mouths quiet you know we
need to keep going forward and we need
to
keep plugging away and doing how it's
how it's going because it's going
so well regardless of the coronavirus
but i feel that there are a lot of
people
that are going to be voting for trump
that are just lying low right now
would you say also that perhaps people
are saying that these are issues that
actually transcend partisan politics
that this is now about the future it is
about the economy
and that this is that that that's where
the commitment has to be is more to your
community as a whole or to your family
than to perhaps the party that you
belong to for so long as a democrat
absolutely um you know everyone is
working together and that's what's
very important and we're seeing it you
know the the way
he has helped the minors with the minds
that we have going on the tariffs
everything else that is going on he is
actually someone who does what he says
he's going to do and that's what's
refreshing
and needed right now and i'm i got
emails from all over
um yesterday between all week actually
and i had a gentleman call me
from georgia today and he said he would
he had voted for
obama the last two um two terms and he
voted for trump this time he said he's
sick of things
being made elsewhere we need to make all
this stuff in the united states again we
need to bring this back and that
includes mining
we have the safest strictest standards
in minnesota
and that's what we need to focus on and
not rely on other other countries
well mayor thank you thank you very much
great stuff and you speaking up of
course i think will be inspirational to
even more than that extra one you just
you just got thank you so much for
joining us great job